tails don't brush my name is Pat today
we're playing three free games the first
game is called towel required holy [ __ ]
beside sixty music I think old men are
chasing me naked
but the music is so distracting that
let's let's hide in the back good thing
I'm super fast gun signing
both people should not be allowed to be
naked it's gross and they should just
stop okay there we go
[ __ ] - sister this is scarier than a
mission
Wow did we have fun today breasts that
was like a video right there but the
thing with my channel that a lot of
people don't realize is I'm like Aaron
you know play I'll play two more games
just for you
I could make three videos out of one
game but no we don't do that
peel the potatoes all right so this game
your job is to peel
take this protector Jess can you feel it
yes I feel it like potatoes am I having
fun
can't you see how much fun are they can
you feel the potato girls can you feel
the potato girl
potato when your hot potato and your but
girl what Wow
that was kind of Awesome I bet you were
like whoo that was a video on its own
right that's what other youtubers would
do that on this channel quality content
as I like to say it all right mix game
is princess now madonna them know look
how cute that is
okay so what do i do we need food
alright so the worker gets this food got
it alright we gave birth to an old
[ __ ] well what are you doing get to
work [ __ ] if anyone knows what the
[ __ ] I'm doing like filth feel free to
tell me
I'm gonna end there because I feel like
Satan is involved somehow and I just
feel like it's not safe for the children
again what are you doing I have a job
you know I got people to entertain
can you stop your ruin my life yeah dude
don't kiss back we talked about this boy
oh boy that was a credit so wasn't it
thank you both so much for watching if
you enjoyed please leave a like if you
want to you know it takes a second I'm
so sorry I make you do it but it helps
and that
is the greatest game of all paths what
is what is this what even